hey youtubers is charlie so huge news JJ
Abrams just released the official names
of the cast members in Star Wars Episode
seven so this is going to be a breakdown
of them also talk about some of the
rumors based on some of their characters
but i'll have a spoiler at the fold in
case you guys don't want to hear about
that stuff i can't imagine how many
people are pounding the internet to find
out if Lucasfilm and Disney are going to
sell these as actual trading cards I
wouldn't be surprised that they did some
sort of collectors edition situation
expect a lot of fun anniversary stuff I
mean this is the first new star wars
film in a long time so yet they're
probably gonna be doing a lot of special
merchandising it would not be star wars
that they didn't saw a load of toys
I will freely admit to shouting shut up
and take my money okay so starting off
with the cast John boyega playing the
stormtrooper Finn mystery person actor
unconfirmed playing kylo Ren the Dark
Jedi or Sith Warrior however you want to
think about him we'll talk about in a
sec during rumors he could be an
Inquisitor Millennium Falcon
self-explanatory Oscar Isaac playing PO
Dameron who seems kinda like the new
Wedge Antilles Daisy Ridley playing ray
bebe 88 is the name of the soccer droid
that everyone's been laughing about its
being referred to as a gendered female
droid just like c-3po is viewed as like
a male droid and then there are also
cards for the x-wings in formation and
the new storm troopers those are likely
just to confirm that what we're seeing
are stormtroopers and x-wings I saw some
people commenting that the x-wings
looked a little bit like z-95
headhunters so now's where we get into
the rumor mill so just general spoiler
warning these are just rumors so I don't
really consider the spoilers but just in
case starting with john-boy hagas
character so he is the rumor protagonist
of the film I mean it's an ensemble cast
so there's gonna be a lot of main
characters but he's like what you would
view Luke Skywalker as in the original
trilogy he is a stormtrooper so clearly
he starts out in the Empire force
awakens meaning he hears a call of sorts
like they learned about the force or
something like the force and seek out
Luke Skywalker to learn more about it
he's joined by ray who's rumored to be a
scavenger heading out under a pseudonym
on the planet like Tatooine it's not
confirmed to be Tatooine but that big
looking modified podracer that she's
driving looks like it's just used for
hauling cargo because all the broken
podracer parts in the background of the
trailer I am thinking that this is
Tatooine she's rumored to be the
daughter of Han and Leia or one of their
children the other one being Adam driver
but that's unconfirmed this droid here
BB 88 is rumored to be hers I think that
idea stands up just because all the
broken podracer parts and all the scrap
metal in the background she probably
uses it for a number of things just like
Luke used r2d2 and c3po for various
tasks the scene with the Falcon is
rumored to be their escape John boyega
and Daisy Ridley's escaped with han Solo
and chewy from Tatooine like when
they're going off to find Luke very
similar to episode 4 when they're
leaving a mid blaster fire we don't
really know what the timeline of the
movie is but i would guess this comes
early on because the movie is supposed
to involve the search for luke skywalker
poe dameron obviously a republic fighter
he's also rumored to be for sensitive
but it's almost like they're setting up
a new trilogy of heroes like you have
John boyega Daisy Ridley and now Oscar
Isaac so think of them is like the Luke
Han and Leia of this new trilogy so
fingers crossed that none of them died
but I have a feeling that the focus will
shift to their characters from the old
characters in this first movie it'll be
like a transition movie and I think I
said it in my previous video but these
x-wings are rumored to be flying over
mon calamari it could be any planet but
that's rumored to be where Luke
Skywalker is hiding out we're supposed
to see the plan in the movie it son
confirmed as to how it's going to appear
how it's going to be featured but it's
just a really exciting place that we
haven't seen on screen so think of like
James Cameron's Avatar and the way they
showed the jungle like this you know
vastly different amazing new place just
forget about the prequel underwater a
Gungan society it's not going to look
like that there's also a lot more rumors
about Andy's circuses character as it
applies to the villains in this movie so
it's rumored that he's not connected to
the Sith he's playing a nonhuman
character that's really really old like
thousands of years old predates
Palpatine and he was using Palpatine for
some dark purpose that will learn about
supposedly he's not going to appear in
the first film at all like he'll be
voiceover will get voiceover but he
won't appear till the second film which
is very much like what the Emperor did
in the original trilogy we saw him as a
hologram in the first film and then we
saw him for real in the second film so
Andy Serkis is not going to be the
Emperor he's not going to be Palpatine
could be something much more grand much
more alien much more mysterious so I'm
actually really excited about that so
all those are just rumors but you can
let me know here's my big question for
you guys what do you think about the
idea of
circuses character being something much
more ancient than the Sith you know not
being a sooth character but working some
grand design with the force I am just as
a huge fan of andy serkis I cannot wait
to see what he looks like and what he
does he's like the king of motion
capture the fact that zelo rent is a
male sounding name kind of explodes
theories that gwendoline christie is
playing that Dark Jedi she is rumored to
be an Inquisitor though inquisitors Dark
Jedi Sith characters all very different
we don't really know what the role the
sipp is going to be in this new movie
they might not be present at all so you
can just call this character wielding
the lightsaber whatever you want Stephen
Colbert had some funny comments about
the crossguard lightsaber too he just
said that the blade actually goes
through the hilt so it really is like a
three-way blade like it doesn't have to
separate blade sticking out he was just
saying that in response to the criticism
that a separate lightsaber would just
slice right through one of those site
hilts onto someone's hand and cut it off
I really do like all the talk about the
lightsaber it's funny how much people
got crazy about it you can let me know
what your opinion is about it I'm kind
of along for the ride so I'm withholding
judgment till I see some more footage
I'm not expecting to see any new
trailers until we get closer to
celebration I think they'll show up some
exclusive footage of the convention and
then do something for star wars day may
be attached a trailer to Avengers 2
because it's going to be released right
around that time so I'm really excited
to start rolling into some new Star Wars
bonus videos and I'm working on my
lightsaber video i'll try and post that
soon be sure to subscribe to get
everything all in all i'm just really
excited to be doing a lot of Star Wars
movie videos it's been a long time but
this is definitely reignited my interest
in the franchise quick heads up if
you're on your mobile phone or on a
tablet there's new links you can click
on up here they keep changing where it
is but it's is the same as the links
over here but right now click here for
the episode 7 trailer breakdown in my QA
and click here to learn all about what's
going on with Marvel in phase 3 they
came so much watching let's all high
five I will see you guys tonight me me
me me me me